[Music]
which is absolutely astonishing I never
thought we would see this it's sitting
here doing nothing - spinning here
hormones already month
people have put this in their recycling
bins they thought it was gonna be
recycled and yet it's just stuck in this
logjam what they actually gave you from
the UK was a mix of who knows what I'm
not supposed to getting this no one
wants it
there was high hopes for this
it's gonna be recycled it was gonna have
a new life now because it's been shipped
like this
it's just landfill father
[Music]
[Music]
we've never consumed so much and a lot
of it is plastic we produce 20 times
more plastic today than we did 50 years
ago I want to find out what happens to
it all where does it go and how much of
it actually gets recycled
what I discovered was a system that
pushes the problem off our shores
the end result plastic piling up and it
isn't going away it all starts here at
home like a lot of families we produce
our fair share of waste I think we're a
bit different when it comes to recycling
I think I'm a good recycler but what do
you think two-thirds of us admit to
being confused about what can and can't
be recycled plastic bottles and tins
bottles that's recyclable plastic
presumably that's what's wrong with that
people talk about washing it but I'm
just not sure whether you need to do
that I just get it finish with it as
soon as they're finished with it I just
bring it in the bin done this isn't
recyclable film but it's plastic so this
shouldn't be in that bin did you put it
in I do fight I genuinely do find the
whole thing very confusing and I'm not
convinced that it's actually worth doing
so why is it up to me I want to know
more so I'm hitching a ride with the
guys who collect my own recycling bins
there are 450 councils with varying
collection schemes and differing rules
about what can and can't be recycled if
you don't get it right it won't be
collected
[Music]
[Music]
you want to see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tell me now because
[Music]
so you're washing your big pots out and
you sort your glass baking sins wash out
if not smelling all the time the bins
are the day's collection ends here my
local depo
it's then picked up and hauled off to a
sorting plant
and there's a lot of it in just one year
British households throw 22 million tons
of waste into the bin EU targets demand
that we recycle half of that by 2020 but
rates are stagnating it just 44%
[Music]
I started in this job in January
it opened my eyes to recycling we're not
going to places like these you see em
which can actually go into a lorry it's
very very distressing
20 today you think 20 20 day or two but
if you thought all of that plastic ended
up being recycled then you're in for a
big shock all this plastic might get
collected but it doesn't mean it'll get
another life we know that we used to
recycle very little indeed we know that
if you take some products you are
recycling probably 40 or 50 percent of
what what goes into the marketplace but
we know on other things that we're
actually recycling practically nothing
on a global scale the numbers are
staggering 78 million tons of plastic
packaging get produced every year and
then after very often a very short use
just 14% of the plastic packaging gets
collected for recycling and even less of
that just 2% gets recycled at high
quality into new packaging then another
14% gets burnt after use another 40%
gets landfills and I quite staggering
one thirds of all plastic packaging ends
up polluting the environment
I found it astonishing that around the
world only 2% of our plastic packaging
gets recycled I wanted to see what
happened with my plastic when I was in
my kitchen the other day my children
even their yogurt pots as we do a lot
from time to time those yogurt pots end
up in here right absolutely absolutely
those yogurt pots end up here along with
about 60 thousand tons of other people
chocolate pots to it of course we're
here by the time my Recycling's landed
here it's traveled nearly 200 miles and
gone through countless hands it's an
industry that employs nearly 20,000 were
we take in material from people's bins
and we turn it back into resources by
the time the waste that's behind you
leaves here it's actually quite a
valuable commodity explain what the
market is like for plastic in the moment
the market for plastic is it's fairly
volatile but it's fairly strong it's all
resources all of this is resources and I
don't want to wait a bit we want to turn
those into the maximum value for the
market we possibly can it turns out that
a lot of our plastic doesn't get
processed here it's exported overseas
and one country has taken more of it
than any other China we live in a
commercial world it's no different to
any other material it will go wherever
the market demand is it will go to the
highest bidder China has been an
important market for the export of
plastics from the UK
China imports 10 million tons of classic
they don't do it just to get plastic at
home they do it because they needed to
feed the manufacturing process it's a
value commodity it's a resource that
gets used to produce products it's not a
way of disposing a material but as
China's appetite for plastic scrap
increased the big problem started to
develop whole villages grew dedicated to
sorting through the world's filthy
plastic one man documented what he found
I'd like you to carve India Oh trouble I
get a gimbal triple IG inevitable like a
little bit come in window okay can I try
namah namah namah balaji me with you
Carol are you sure don't go
so don't know you can fit onto my a
juicer don't poet gentlemen will you go
together like it fit under the adduction
come on Elijah to shower me return it to
them the largest tuna her handsome up a
true leader sure who you will fire you
di di don't go high eating for that
teacher doing with your shine
it was a wake-up call for China who saw
this as a big problem they had to deal
with their reaction would send
shockwaves around the world I'm trying
to find out what happens to all our
recycling it's a journey that's taken me
thousands of miles to the other side of
the world
Hong Kong is the world's gateway to
China it's through this artery that much
of the world's plastic scrap passes on
its way to be processed on the mainland
in July 2017 China rocked the recycling
world by announcing it would impose
tough restrictions on the import of
foreign waste they called it national
sword
we've become more more conscious of
waste
we've seen a lot more publicity more and
more people know that they want to
recycle they get very frustrated when
they can but they don't know where it
goes
this assumption that it will be being
reprocessed and made into good things in
the UK but frequently it's not because
easier and cheaper to put into a
container and send it through on to
China why not
government equally is it's moving the
problem away it's still achieving our
recycling targets
they've been said but it's maybe it's
somebody else's expense
just trying to sum up to me what our
policy of the UK has been regarding
China
she needs a solution let's put in a
container in felixstowe and wave bye-bye
but China is saying I'm having for a
little while why are we receiving your
mixed rubbish so they became normal
straight under a program called national
sword china's message was brutally clear
any dirty contaminated plastic would be
flatly rejected the kind of plastic
Britain's been sending China for decades
we export about 60% of the packaging
plastic waste that we collect and of
that two-thirds that we export about a
third 40% of that goes to China
operational national sword had big
impact in that it's always half the
amount of plastic in China that's the
problem that we've now got China who are
now saying actually we don't want this
low quality stuff anymore so we're going
to close our doors and you're going to
have to find somewhere else finding
somewhere else
for the plastic is proving very
difficult I've come to meet Tony Wong
he's been trading plastic for 20 years
and he has a lot of it sitting in this
yard in Hong Kong because China won't
take it so this is full of varying
amounts of plastic it is
it's about a value of that over $10,000
but now because stuck in here and that
the market changed because of the
importing maybe $7,000 20% down so stuff
that's been washed in clean and this is
good stuff for you nothing wrong with
this nothing at all look at this
even though spout and I can see you're
very passionate about this this is I see
the money I see I see the business to me
not like sonic oh well it's a cold in
here
it's very standard kind of items buzz
you just need a country that's willing
to take it of course yes and that's the
problem
yes to put home for them to turn back
into value this is now the world's
bottleneck for plastic scrap tons of it
stuck in limbo the big question now
where's it all going to go
meet the man who's made his fortune in
recycling Steve Wong works with Tony to
import tens of thousands of tons of
plastic through Hong Kong to be
processed in China
these plastic film bags have come over
on the container from the United Kingdom
to here to your place
[Music]
but China's ban means Steve has to ship
his plastics somewhere else he's looking
to neighboring countries in which to
process China's unwanted plastic he's
heading to Thailand and I'm going with
him
[Music]
over several days I followed Steve from
site to site he's running out of time to
find a place which is capable of dealing
with the plastic he wants to recycle
[Music]
where is what is that
myself experience to feel about it
the big question here is whether
Thailand can cope with what China is
rejecting
[Music]
what we saw it one processing plant put
all that in doubt here we found
recycling from the UK sitting we were
told for more than a year
then more disturbing biohazard bags
being melted down to be turned into
anything from children's toys to
household appliances
and tastes like more decent than this
place
please quite messy I see water
everywhere
and although their production right now
is see not a broken machine
[Music]
what struck me was the bags and bags of
well non recyclable waste that was some
of it was clearly from the UK that was
just gonna sit there for however long is
that a sign of what can get through the
system what can slip through the net I
think this is why China stopping pottage
on the plastic wrap
because exporters they thought they did
anything the ban on importing recycled
plastics into China can be a great
opportunity for the UK it forces the UK
to rethink how they deal with their
plastics post use it can also go the bad
way where we would continue exporting
the plastics for abroad where the
infrastructure is even worse than in
China
and where we have to believe it gets
recycled because we have collected and
sorted and send it there but actually
what happens there is it perhaps gets
burnt or it gets treated in a way that's
negative for the local environment I
wanted to know how Britain would cope if
we had to deal with our own plastic
instead of sending it abroad what's
gonna happen when China closes the door
it wasn't gonna be good news I've spent
months investigating what happens to our
recycling of all a plastic we've been
sending abroad all these years a
staggering 60 percent of exports have
been going to one place China
problem is they don't want it anymore
I've come to one of the biggest plastic
processors in Britain to find out why
we've been sending so much material
abroad and where all this plastic is
gonna go now
Petey is in the region of 200 pounds a
ton that's carbonated drinks and water
bottles milk bottles detergent bottles
they're about 300 pounds of top
why are you exporting it why can't we
just deal with it here in the UK
restrictions in the UK's capacity
historically that hasn't been a growth
that matches the recovery of the
materials from the waste management
authorities and local authorities the
capacity doesn't meet the demand we're
not a big island we've got small amount
of land mass where do we put this
material I think it's a failing in the
system it's easier to put it in a
container and export it rather than
spend significant amounts of money
putting a processing plant it's
well-known that there is a poor auditing
system for materials that go overseas to
China or Asia particularly it's
generally out of sight out of mind
I'd rather not know what's happening to
it as long as it's not on our back door
truth of the matter is is that we will
have no idea at all whether this gets a
new life actually properly recycled no
we don't we don't know whether it's burn
buried or just left on the side of the
street so we don't have enough processes
to deal with all our plastic but there's
another reason we've been pushing our
waste abroad all these years the
packaging recovery note or PRM is a
government subsidy designed to encourage
recycling let's take a turn of plastic
scrap
a UK recycler processes that plastic and
because of contaminants like labels
glues or liquids might only get half a
ton of recycled plastic from it they
would earn half a subsidy or half a PRN
however an exporter can take that ton of
plastic scrap contaminates and all and
ship it off to be recycled abroad that
turn of scrap is counted as fully
recycled and the full PRN subsidy is
earned but no checks are made as to how
much recycled plastic is actually
produced and so it encourages export PRN
system was designed to subsidize the
recycler to help him confidence to
invest in more equipment that will
recycle more material that will then
grow the infrastructure in the UK but
unfortunately the system was designed
but it was weighted towards the exporter
for that whole bale would be eligible
for a PRN whereas those as a recycler
we're only eligible for what we separate
and reprocess
the wait for the exporter is much more
attractive than that of the recycler so
once it goes in this container the whole
container gets issued with that evidence
no direct whereas if you have to deal
with it in the UK it might only be like
40 50 percent if you're looking correct
so the incentive is to bug it in a
container and send it away still get the
credit for it in fact for all of it
rather than deal with it here in the UK
correct correct we're not getting the
full value of that subsidy whereas the
exporter is getting the full value by
weight it seemed to me that the ban
imposed by China could actually be an
opportunity for British business Javed
Mao ji set up his own plastic processing
business in 2014 he tried to do the
right thing by recycling here in the UK
how would you describe how britain's
recycling industry what state do you
think it is in it's absolutely terrible
I mean the it's a it's a mishmash it
doesn't work properly and it's the whole
structure of the British recycling
sector at the moment seems to be focused
on export the wastes don't process it
here because there's no incentive to
process anything here there's an
incentive export when it launched Jabez
company Ecotec was doing well
but success was short-lived he just
couldn't compete with the exporters how
does it feel coming back to it that's
pretty unpleasant Ashley but I mean I
haven't been back here since the company
went into administration there's a very
very painful process not only
financially but also in terms of lost
jobs and also in terms of lost capacity
for the UK's recycling business so we we
as a UK company we would get a PRN on
what actually came out the other end
so whereas if you were exporting you
would get a PRN on the entire value so
if you export plastic bottles on the
records you've recycled all of them
that's correct but not necessarily all
of them were recycled that's exactly but
it had absolutely no bearing on the
figure that was jotted down on the book
well I think I think that the reality is
is the UK was liking rates are
exaggerated by the PRN system so you in
a way would say that you you were a
victim of that system absolutely yeah
and so what is the incentive from the
government to get rid of a system which
is favorable to our recycling rates well
it's it's it's it looks like we were
cycling far more than we are
[Music]
it's a problem what that system does not
only does it mean we're over reporting
recycle rates
we're actually undermining the
competitiveness of our own domestic
plastic reprocesses we're actually
exporting value we could be reprocessing
that material here we had better quality
material if we were making sure that we
were accounting for the reciting
properly we would not have this
competitive disadvantage for our
domestically processes these are being
those overseas
it is a serious flaw that we don't know
well enough what happens to quite a bit
of the recycling we export a lot of
plastic to be recycled I myself think
that we should have a system where we
are much more likely to use that at home
because you know where it's gone
if you export it and it's increasingly
difficult to do that
the Chinese are increasingly not
accepting it you don't always know where
it's gone this is where it's gone I was
about to discover what happens when the
recycling system fails there are
thousands of tons of plastic scrap lying
in this yard shipped from the UK in
containers tons and tons of plastic
sitting in a yard on the outskirts of
Hong Kong doing nothing to it spinning
here for months already I haven't go to
the site to look at the material you
sent me the photos which of course not
like this
what were you expecting we're expanding
on a bottle
and what did you actually get in the end
film Richard plastics and even some
pavement here no one willing to handle
it ok the one winning because labor
intensive no one wants it no one wants
it it's just landfill fodder
it was an extraordinary sight this
recycling had been collected and then
shipped just like the system encouraged
now it had been left to rot how do you
feel about the person who shipped this
to you
then we found bags from Chelmsford
Council in Essex and I realized that
this plastic had travelled nearly six
thousand miles
hundreds of tons of plastic recycling
from British homes sits in Hong Kong
destined for landfill it's a shocking
sight and disheartening to think that
people have taken the time to sort it
thinking they were doing the right thing
amongst it all we found household
recycling bags from Chelmsford Council
in Essex so I went to Chelmsford Council
to see what they know about where their
recycling goes and what's ultimately
done with it a lot of priorities do
these are collection system bags we
allow about 3.5 per week through the
residents which we deliver free of
charge once a year we put a lot of trust
in the people that take away obviously
our material
I went to Hong Kong two weeks ago I find
a yard like this this arrow is a pack of
recycling from the UK
unfortunately that comes from Chelmsford
Council it was not to the quality that
the the receiving end wanted and so it
was rejected and the unfortunate fact is
that you can never tell where your
materials going I think that will be
absolutely investigated there's no way
we can be happy about that no no from
what you've just highlighted something
has gone wrong down the road which
obviously raises a huge question for us
doesn't it really one will be
investigated and once we find out the
detail behind it we would take steps to
take whatever steps are needed to
resolve it we don't want the idea that
our material is ending up in a landfill
site on foreign lands or or in a yard
somewhere we want to make sure that
material is being recycled as we've
explained to our residents then I
received a package sent anonymously
photographs of plastic packaging from
the UK destined for recycling but now it
appeared left sitting on a site in
Poland it looked like another case in
which the system had gone badly wrong I
wanted to know more so I headed to
Poland and took along an expert on
plastic packaging to take a look
approaching the East End district of
twenty years of being involved in
packaged in weeks the last fifteen so
bills or plastic it's quite common so
this yard is owned by a British plastics
exporter the same exporter whose plastic
we found in Hong Kong it's a mix of
bottles tubs food trays and film all
piled up in bales oh this is carrier
bags
wow these are beyond you say Clank Wow
the first thing is its degraded to such
a level it's not really viable for
recycling it's not really suitable for
the safe in it anything that's held
stored on a safe for over 12 months has
deemed to be aimed disposal and
therefore a landfill and that that could
be that can be deemed as a train and
there could be prosecution types and
taken against to me it looks like it's
inevitable destinations a landfill so
it looks like curbside recycling
certainly this carrier bags there that
from a local council that's sure that
householders going to the effort of
putting all their plastic waste into a
bag this is Chelmsford Council it's not
the first time I've seen a Chelmsford
council bag in a place where you
wouldn't expect these are mixed waste
feels what it means as it's cardboard
metals plastic all mixed together and
the if they've come from the UK and
certainly with some of the containers on
here it looks like they're from the UK
they shouldn't be exported what is the
chance that this was brought here to be
recycled because of the high amount of
cardboard in it and it's being stored
outside there's no chance of this being
recycled plastic scrap shipped from the
UK can earn a packaging recovery note or
PRN that's the evidence note to say
something's being recycled but no one
checks to see if it's actually being
recycled and incredibly it counts as
recycled towards our EU target the
exporter gets paid no matter what I mean
you could say that the whole package
recovery note system for exporters is
like just like money for nothing license
to print money you could say that but
the intention of the system was that the
money from prm's would go back into
increasing infrastructure but it looks
like in some cases it's being abused
I think the systems got that inherent
risk in it
when things are transported across
countries across boundaries it's very
difficult to keep track of them
the amount off and I'll call it pure
waste that is lying on the ground the
films that have degree deeds the carrier
bags that are freaking into nothing and
it's highly unlikely those were going to
be recycled so effectively they've been
brought here to cool and told to get
disposed off we found more evidence of
plastic from Britain ending up overseas
and some of it was so badly decayed that
landfill was the only option we
contacted Chelmsford Council again to
tell them we'd seen more of their
recycling in Poland after looking into
it
Chelmsford confirmed that the plastic
we'd found in Hong Kong and Poland had
gone through companies accredited as re
processors and exporters of packaging
waste from the Environment Agency they
said they remain confident their
approach has the least environmental
impact of all recycling practices the
reason why Britain has been sending so
much plastic overseas is that the PRN
system actively encouraged it among
those who are critical of the scheme is
the man who came up with the idea in the
first place former Environment Minister
John Gummer now Lord eben there are
several problems with it first of all I
don't think we have sufficient control
over where it goes
secondly I don't think we have
sufficient control over the quality of
what is in there in other words you can
have mixed up in that material things
that are not going to be recycled and
the third thing is China is now from the
1st of January not to accept it I think
we ought to be recycling it here and in
the rest of Europe but the problem is as
you well know is the the problem with
the PRN or the PRN system is it
incentivizes export it does in certain
circumstances you are incentivized to
export it that's nonsense and shouldn't
happen and we should change it
in 2015 Defra commissioned a series of
independent briefing notes looking at
the PRN scheme we've obtained them they
raised concerns about the system the
briefing notes warmed that competition
is insufficient and there's a lack of
transparency and that local counsel so
little if any benefit from the money
raised the system was seen to favor
export with low quality waste providing
a cheap disposal route for contaminants
and worryingly the papers repeated
concerns that the PRN scheme doesn't
work to encourage investment in the UK
reprocessing industry but these briefing
notes were never made public and no
changes were made to the PRN system
in tune Michael Gove was appointed
Environment Secretary and walked
straight into a crisis
a month later China said they'd ban
imports at the start of 2018 a committee
of MPs wanted to know what the new
environment secretary was going to do
about it
what impact do you think this will have
on the UK waste economy will have it's a
very good question and something to
which I'll be completely honest I want
to firstly just go back to November 2
that environmental audit committee where
they were talking about the impact of
the ban that China is intending to
impose on plastic imports and you'll
remember you said that you hadn't given
it much thought given that British
business British processors believed
that this is huge do you regret that yes
it's a significant issue I haven't given
it enough thought but what we're doing
now is everything we can in order to
ensure that we turn what is a challenge
into an opportunity we've been exporting
too much waste what we need to do is to
make sure that we reduce the amount that
we produce and also process more of it
at home do you think that we have the
capacity now to deal with the plastic
that would have otherwise gone to China
naturally the fact that China's going to
close its doors to a significant amount
of that plastic that's an additional
challenge on us here in the UK I want to
talk about capacity because I want to
spend the next minute of this interview
just showing you some footage that we
filmed in Poland and in hong kong
it shows tens of thousands of tons of
plastic on yards that has been abandoned
what's your view about what you've just
seen well it reinforces the case for the
reforms that I've already explained that
we plan to implement that the PRN scheme
at the moment while it has significantly
improved recycling rates and recycling
rates have grown over the course of the
last 20 years it's still not good enough
then the government revealed its long
awaited 25 year plan for the environment
in that plan the government provided no
details of any proposed changes to the
PRN scheme
we're probably deluding ourselves we
think we have a system that's better
than it is and actually if it isn't a
very good system well we should improve
it but it must be recognizing that
helping the environment does come at a
cost the cheap way is let's dump it
somewhere else I don't think we're
planning quick enough and I think it
means investment I think it means
government support and I think we need
facilities such as these to accept that
volume of material we have to look at
reprocessing it domestically it's our
waste our problem we should be recycling
it
when I first started this journey I had
no idea where our recycling ended up but
I found it
scattered thousands of miles across the
globe abandoned in yards from Eastern
Europe to Asia out of sight out of mind
what I learned was that until we as a
nation take responsibility for what we
put in our bins create a system we can
trust this problems going to pile up and
we can't afford to ignore it
[Music]
[Music]